In Alteryx, we're going to leverage the
same tool we have been using to validate
our individual models to compare all
three of our models side by side,
the model comparison tool.
So, as you see on the canvas,
we have all three models already built
out since we've done that already.
What I'm going to do now is union
the three model objects together, and
then load those into the model
comparison report, so I'm able to
determine which model actually performs
better by looking at them side by side.
So, let's bring in now a union tool
to union the three model
objects in together.
Then I'll bring in a model comparison
tool, and load those union results with
the model objects into the M, our model
input for the model comparison tool.
And the validation dataset goes
into then the D, our data side.
Let's bring in a browse tool
after the R output, and
let's kick off this workflow.
So now that this ran,
let's open up this result output so
we can go and interpret the results.
What we're able to see here is
all the models side by side for
their fit and error measures.
So, we're able to determine
each of the individual models
total accuracy with that
validation dataset,
as well as how well each of the models
performed at trying to predict
each mode of transportation
within that validation dataset.
The other thing we're able to look
at is the confusion matrices of
each of the different models
with that validation dataset
to see if there's any trends or
biases within this model.